everybody likes free games and  PlayStation Plus gives them to you and  now we know what's coming next month I'm  Tony and this is your PlayStation Plus  may line up ps4 players get three games  next month instead of the usual two  they're getting tropico 5 and table top  racing world tour switch galaxy ultra is  coming to both ps4 and PS vita vita  owners can also grab god of war ghost of  sparta meanwhile ps3 players are getting  bionic commando rearmed to and loco roco  coca recho any of those sound good to  you PS pluses may game x tweak when the  PlayStation Store refreshes until then  you can still grab any of april's free  games including dead star and shoot see  me to stay up to date with all the  playstation news keep it locked to  gamespot  you